[Music]
first of all people's reactions are so
like visceral and strong is it what is
it about taking someone's car obviously
you know when you take somebody
somebody's vehicle man they get hot on
the Billy Goats but no pepper patch yeah
that's just yeah just as I would have
set it myself harder than a billy goats
button a pepper patch so this is what
you do this is a you're illiterate how
did this show kind of this become a
television show that's what I'm always
interested in how did this become a TV
show it's a favorite question go ahead
it is is most people don't know Amy's a
former world champion power lifter she's
also a licensed mortician and she's also
an MMA fighter and why SWAT came to us
and wanted to put us on a show and they
didn't understand that she was mean on a
rattlesnake with a loose tooth and I
didn't want to put that on any other
husband in America right you know so we
decided not to do wife swap so they sent
this guy out from the Bronx he was
tougher tattoo allah pig steak and he
was gonna film us three hours later one
gunshot we have a TV show faster than a
billy goat on you thank you yeah now
okay so this is how it became a show Ron
did you always work in the repo business
is that something you've always done no
sir I actually uh I was in college
trying to do a little college football
worked my way through college and I was
on the house and I got struck by
lightning you're on a house yes sir I
was roof or not when we grew up me and
my brother was so poor we had to ride
double on our state course so we worked
our way through life I'm gonna look into
that that's a lie I'm coming bro double
on a stick horse so you're on top of a
roof thing yes you're struck by
lightning yes sir you fall off the roof
yes sir knock me off the roof I woke up
and it was all these bright lights and
the first thing I asked a lady she was
really pretty and I asked her I said it
I just go to heaven she said no you're
going to the hospital okay no so I
couldn't play football anymore I
couldn't you pay my way through college
and my brother on a small car lot so he
put me behind a desk Bo but you know I
kind of felt like a bumblebee in a book
of the taller I just always felt like I
was stuck
so he come up to me one day and said
would you like to go find out soon would
you like to go pick up some of my cars I
said bow to rattlesnakes kiss gently I'm
on it and I've been recalling 15 years
I'd love to see a transcript of this
okay
now you sneak up on people to get their
cars and you and Ron you're not above
using Amy as a decoy aren't you worried
about her safety and explain how you
used her as a decoy well I mean like I
said I'm stuffing a $3 pig steak I'm
worried about the people were going
after
hey what about her yeah exactly nice
when a man says you're tougher than a
three dollar pig steak hard somewhere to
my three dollar pig steak so so how does
he use you as a decoy he has you go to
the door sometimes or act as it don't
you act as a stranded motorist at times
yes I have I've done a stranded motorist
and then basically what happens is is
they're all focused on me and he's
mixing it's the car
amazing what we saw in that clip in and
out quick we were looking at that clip
that we just saw of the large gentleman
with the crazy hair who was I think
trying to kill you with firecrackers
yeah and and and he seems obviously you
look at that gun you think that guy's
dangerous but sometimes there are people
who are dangerous who you wouldn't even
expect old ladies can be dangerous when
you repossess their cars is that true
Oh ladies and handguns can't do nothing
with them you can't beat the elderly but
I tell you what I've never seen Ronnie
run so fast when that old lady pulled
her gun out of Bible
well you can't just say it like that I
explained what happened you know you
know what I'm the lady oh no wait how
does Johnny in a Bible basically what
happened is Ronnie was being kind
hearted and said look I'll let you get
your stuff out if you give me the keys
so we could just drive off getting back
to the lien holder the lady said sir I
want one is my Bible Lonnie said all
right sure she gets back there next
thing he knows she's got a gun cord and
Ronnie like you can keep the car right
I've gone and she kept the gun she had
hollowed out the Bible and kept a gun in
there yes I mean some people you know
some people you know the brains were
gasoline they couldn't drive a Pearson
has to go call half around a cheerio but
uh she was small enough for that gun in
that bob think I've got you this time no
no no it works okay and I learned one
thing you don't have to be fast you just
got to be fast me your cameraman okay